L'ordre du jour
appelle les questions
au gouvernement.
La première va être posée
par le président Pancher
pour le groupe LIOT.
- Bertrand Pancher:
Mon engagement politique,
comme tous
les parlementaires
de mon groupe,
a toujours été guidé
par la recherche
de mesures efficaces
et justes.
Efficaces
car nos concitoyens
sont de plus en
plus désabusés
de la politique
et ils croient
de moins en la parole publique.
Les valeurs de la République
sont primordiales
à nos yeux, notamment
l'idéal de fraternité.
Il y a quelques semaines,
vous vous étiez engagé
à présenter un texte
sur l'immigration,
attendu par de nombreux Français.
Le groupe LIOT a depuis le début
rappelé l'importance
de présenter
un texte équilibré
et sans extrémisme.
C'est à cela
que nous avons oeuvré
en commission
avec l'interdiction
du classement en lieu
de rétention administrative
de tous les mineurs
ou l'intégration
par la langue.
Le texte s'éloigne
dans sa rédaction
de son objectif principal.
Nous souhaitions,
comme les Français,
un vrai débat.
Nous en sommes privés.
Les Français
sont médusés face
à des intrigues
et des entourloupes
d'un autre temps,
dans une commission mixte
paritaire opaque.
Quel spectacle
est-ce que nous donnons?
C'est un échec collectif.
Notre démocratie est malade.
Nous avons besoin
de plus de transparence,
de concertation,
de recherche de consensus.
C'est la grandeur
de notre pays
qui en dépend.
Il faut
se ressaisir
collectivement avant
que les extrémistes
ne prennent le pouvoir
dans notre pays.
Madame la Première
ministre, la loi
qui va sortir
de CMP sera-t-elle
plus efficace?
En quoi ce texte
sera-t-il plus juste?
Quand y aura-t-il
dans notre pays
un chef démocratique?
Quand est-ce qu'on écoutera
le Parlement
en le laissant
délibérer sereinement?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci, la parole
est à madame la Première ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne:
Monsieur le président
Bertrand Pancher,
vous le savez,
et c'est une
préoccupation
que vous et votre groupe
partagez,
nous devons éloigner
plus rapidement
ceux qui n'ont pas le droit
de se maintenir
sur notre sol
et mieux intégrer
ceux que nous choisissons
d'accueillir.
C'est une attente forte
de nos concitoyens,
c'est nécessaire pour notre pays.
Depuis des mois,
avec les ministres Gérald Darmanin
et Olivier Dussopt,
un travail intense
est mené pour bâtir
un texte qui apporte
des réponses efficaces
aux attentes
des Français dans le respect
des valeurs républicaines.
Ces échanges, vous y avez été
largement associé,
ainsi que votre groupe.
La semaine
dernière encore,
nous avons rencontré
le ministre
de l'Intérieur,
avec moi-même
et notre coprésident
Christophe Naegelen.
Vous me posez
des questions claires.
En quoi ce texte
sera-t-il plus efficace?
sera-t-il plus juste?
Je vous réponds clairement.
Ce projet de loi
rendra notre système
plus efficace
car il va simplifier
drastiquement
nos procédures et réduire
les délais de traitement
des demandes d'asile.
Il va permettre d'expulser
plus rapidement
les étrangers délinquants
ou radicalisés.
Il donne des moyens
accrus pour lutter
contre l'immigration illégale.
Il porte des mesures
spécifiques adaptées
à chaque territoire
pour les outre-mer.
Ce n'est pas tout.
Ce projet de loi
rendra notre système
plus juste parce qu'il interdit
le placement
des mineurs en rétention
administrative,
il renforce
les sanctions
contre les passeurs,
il fait pleinement
du travail un levier
d'intégration, notamment
dans les filières en tension.
Avec la majorité,
avec tous les députés
constructifs,
avec votre groupe,
nous voulons un texte solide,
un texte efficace,
un texte juste.
C'est notre cap,
nous nous y tenons.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Bruno Millienne
pour le groupe Démocrate.
- Bruno Millienne: Merci.
Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre
de la Transition écologique
et de la Cohésion des territoires.
Mercredi dernier s'est
terminée la COP28.
Mon groupe, qui plaide
pour une écologie réaliste,
se joint à moi
pour vous féliciter quant
à l'accord
historique
que vous avez négocié
au nom de la France.
N'en déplaise
à nos oppositions,
c'est un accord historique
qui a été trouvé.
L'accord pousse
les pays à abandonner
les combustibles fossiles.
Il envoie un message fort
aux investisseurs
et aux décideurs
politiques, ainsi qu'à
la population.
Il est parfaitement
en phase
avec la politique
énergétique engagée
par notre majorité depuis six ans.
Il prouve que nous allons
dans le bon sens,
le sens de l'histoire.
Cela n'avait rien
d'évident à l'ouverture
de cette COP.
Nous sommes passés
d'un accord
trop peu ambitieux
à un accord
à la hauteur des enjeux.
La France
est l'un des pays
les moins émetteurs
de gaz à effet
de serre et l'un
de ceux qui baissent
le plus drastiquement
ses émissions.
Au premier semestre
2023, la France
a baissé ses émissions de 4,3%.
Cette baisse est portée
par le bâtiment,
avec une baisse de 7%.
En comparaison
avec le quinquennat
de François Hollande,
nous avons doublé
nos baisses annuelles.
Elle ne fut que de 24
millions de tonnes
entre 2012 et 2017,
contre 55 millions
pour nous.
Chaque pays devra présenter
de nouveaux engagements
en 2025 en fonction
des orientations données
à Dubaï.
Pourriez-vous nous détailler
les grandes lignes
de ce que seront ces engagements?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Christophe Béchu,
ministre de la Transition
écologique
et de la Cohésion des territoires.
- Christophe Béchu:
Madame la présidente,
monsieur le député
Bruno Millienne,
le dérèglement
climatique s'accélère.
Ses effets
sont de plus en plus visibles,
nous le constatons
partout sur la planète,
entre les mégafeux du Canada,
les inondations
à certains endroits.
Cette COP de Dubaï
était annoncée
comme une réunion
de la dernière chance.
Elle n'était pas placée
sous les meilleurs auspices,
avec un président
qui est à la tête
d'une compagnie pétrolière.
Elle a pourtant débouché
sur un accord historique,
pour au moins trois raisons.
Pour la première
fois, 196 pays
dans le monde
se sont mis d'accord
pour indiquer
que la transition devait
se faire hors
des énergies fossiles.
Pour la première
fois, une COP
avec 196 pays
a consacré la place
du nucléaire.
Pour la première
fois, l'engagement
de tripler la capacité
des énergies renouvelables
a été prise par 196 pays.
Tous ces éléments soulignent
la nécessité d'une diplomatie
environnementale puissante.
Ce n'est pas en discutant
qu'avec
des gens
avec qui on est d'accord
que l'on arrive à des accords.
Avant l'accord de Paris,
la trajectoire
du réchauffement mondial
était de 4 degrés.
Ces moments
permettent à chacun
d'être à la fois
derrière la science
et la réalité
de ce qui nous attend.
Il n'y a que deux catégories
de gens
qui sont profondément déçus:
les climato-populistes
qui disent qu'il n'y
a pas de réchauffement climatique,
et je pense
à l'extrême droite,
et les climato-défaitistes
qui aimeraient garder
le monopole de la lutte
contre le dérèglement climatique.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à madame
Sylvie Bonnet
pour le groupe Les Républicains.
- Sylvie Bonnet:
Madame la présidente,
ma question
s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de l'Economie.
Le groupe Casino
est une entreprise d'envergure
internationale qui a des racines
profondément ancrées
dans la Loire.
Ce groupe a été
placé en procédure
de sauvegarde accélérée
fin octobre afin
de mettre en oeuvre
la restructuration
de sa dette.
Même si un accord
semble se profiler
avec Intermarché et Auchan,
les 55.000 salariés employés
Je souhaite exprimer
mon profond attachement
à l'entreprise et à ses salariés.
J'en appelle aussi
et surtout à la responsabilité
du gouvernement.
Ce sont des milliers
d'emplois directs
et des dizaines de milliers
d'emplois indirects
qui sont menacés.
3000 personnes au total
dans les sièges sociaux
de Saint-Etienne.
3000 personnes dans les entrepôts.
16.000 personnes
dans les supermarchés
et hypermarchés.
L'enjeu est considérable.
C'est pourquoi
dimanche dernier,
nous étions de nombreux
élus aux côtés
des salariés
qui craignent de perdre
leur emploi.
Pouvez-vous nous dire combien
d'emplois seront sauvés
au siège de Saint-Etienne?
Certains
magasins
ne risquent-ils pas
de fermer
ou d'être confrontés
à des problèmes
de concurrence?
Pouvez-vous rassurer
les milliers
de salariés
et leur famille
à quelques jours de Noël?
Vous engagez-vous
à ce que tous
les employés soient sauvés?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Roland Lescure,
ministre en charge de l'Industrie.
- Roland Lescure:
Merci, madame la députée
Sylvie Bonnet, merci
pour votre question.
Je voudrais aussi
saluer le député
de Saint-Etienne
qui suit ce dossier
de très près.
Applaudissements
C'est notamment
à sa demande que Bruno
Le Maire, que j'excuse
aujourd'hui,
a reçu
l'intersyndicale
il y a quelques jours.
Du fait d'erreurs
stratégiques importantes,
le groupe Casino a été
durablement affaibli
ce dernier trimestre.
Grâce à l'action
du gouvernement cet été,
nous avons retrouvé un repreneur.
Depuis, des pertes
énormes ont conduit
le repreneur à revoir
la situation
et à mettre en vente,
avec l'accord
du propriétaire
actuel, l'ensemble
des hypermarchés
et des supermarchés
de la marque.
Deux offres
se sont présentées vendredi.
Le repreneur a choisi l'offre
la mieux disante
d'un point de vue
social et d'un point
de vue économique,
ainsi que d'un point
de vue logistique.
5 des 13 entrepôts seront sauvés.
Cette reprise
a été acceptée
par le repreneur.
Elle va nous permettre,
et c'est
un engagement ferme
de l'Etat, de maintenir
les locaux de Saint-Etienne.
Les deux opérations de transaction
seront rendues possibles
par Auchan et par Intermarché.
Une bonne partie
des entrepôts
et des supermarchés
vont être repris.
Il y aura un bon
maintien de l'emploi
dans l'ensemble du territoire.
L'Etat sera
extrêmement vigilant
à la qualité
de cette stratégie,
au maintien de l'emploi
à Saint-Etienne,
à la capacité collective
que nous aurons
à donner des perspectives
durables
au groupe Casino.
L'Etat suivra
cette situation
de très près, je m'y
engage devant vous.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Madame la députée?
- Sylvie Bonnet:
Il est regrettable
que monsieur
Bruno Le Maire
ne soit pas là.
Madame la Première
ministre,
j'ai un courrier
à remettre à monsieur
le président
de la République
de la part
de l'intersyndicale
et des parlementaires de la Loire.
Merci.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur
Andy Kerbrat
pour le groupe
La France Insoumise.
- Andy Kerbrat: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Ma question
ne s'adresse pas à Gérald
Darmanin,
le ministre illégitime
de l'Intérieur,
mais à Elisabeth Borne,
cheffe du gouvernement.
Où est passé le barrage
républicain?
du candidat Macron,
réélu en 2022,
qui disait aux Français
que son élection
était leur réponse
à l'extrême droite?
Où est passé le barrage
du candidat Macron
en 2017 qui affirmait
que l'immigration
ne devrait pas inquiéter
la population française?
Où est passé le barrage
du ministre Macron,
qui pensait en 2015
de l'immigration
qu'elle était une réponse
à la dignité
de la population?
Où est passé le barrage
quand le parti
du président
de la République s'apprête
à voter une loi
écrite par Marine
Le Pen et reprise par Eric Ciotti?
S'attaquer aux familles,
instaurer
une préférence nationale
pour les aides sociales,
ce sont des mesures
de Jean-Marie
Le Pen.
Vous avez cédé
sur tous,
et vous avez cédé.
Par aveuglement!
Par orgueil!
Vous passez par-dessus
bord les pratiques
les plus élémentaires
de notre République.
Collègues
de la majorité,
tout nous oppose,
mais nous savons
qui est le véritable ennemi.
C'est la peste brune,
c'est la gangrène mortifère
de la xénophobie.
La meilleure défense
contre l'extrême droite
est de la combattre
en faisant
tout le contraire
de ce qu'elle veut.
Nous tiendrons bon
contre votre projet
de loi, contre le chantage
du Sénat,
contre les idées de Le Pen.
Où serez-vous?
Dans l'arc républicain
ou dans l'arc réactionnaire?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Gérald Darmanin,
ministre de l'Intérieur
et des Outre-mer.
- Gérald Darmanin:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Mesdames et messieurs
les députés, monsieur
le député
de La France Insoumise,
où était votre bonne
morale lorsque
vous avez dragué les voix
du Rassemblement National
pour la motion de rejet?
Où étaient vos valeurs
de gauche
quand vous avez pactisé
avec madame
Le Pen pour ne pas faire
votre travail
de député
et éviter le débat
pendant 15 jours?
Aujourd'hui,
vous faites semblant
de découvrir
la Constitution,
vous faites
semblant de voir
que vous avez rejeté
dans les bras
du Sénat
le texte
que vous n'avez pas voulu étudier!
Désormais, parés
de la morale
et de la vertu,
vous dites regretter
les conséquences
des causes
que vous avez créées.
Monsieur
le député,
vous ne nous ferez pas
croire
que vous êtes dans l'arc
républicain
quand vous draguez les voix
du Rassemblement National.
Vous êtes ne ferez pas
croire
que vous êtes du côté
de la morale lorsque
cette majorité
refuse d'interdire
le placement les centres
de rétention.
Vous ne nous ferez pas
croire
que vous êtes du côté
de la morale
quand vous faites
ce sourire à madame
Le Pen et que vous vous levez
ensemble
pour vous applaudir
devant la mort
de la démocratie parlementaire.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie,
monsieur le ministre.
Monsieur le député?
-
Andy Kerbrat:
Nous ne voterons pas le 22e
texte
sur l'immigration
mais sur ce qui nous définit.
Quelles valeurs
nous donnons à une vie?
Cela définit
notre République
et notre humanité.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
Monsieur le ministre?
- Gérald Darmanin:
Monsieur le député,
vous avez choisi
la politique du pire.
Désormais,
vous pleurez des larmes
de crocodile.
Ces larmes, ce sont celles que
vous avez pactisées
avec le Rassemblement National.
Vous mettrez longtemps
à vous en remettre.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
S'il vous plaît...
On écoute l'orateur suivant,
monsieur Anthony Brosse
pour le groupe Renaissance.
- Anthony Brosse: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à madame
Agnès Pannier-Runacher,
ministre de la Transition
énergétique.
Adoptés il y a huit ans,
les accords
de Paris ont permis d'endiguer
la hausse inexorable
de nos émissions de gaz
à effet de serre.
Sans eux, une hausse de 16%
de nos émissions aurait été
constatée en 2030.
Elles ne seraient
que de 3%
grâce à la COP 2021.
C'est une première
victoire qui reste
à nuancer.
Ces 3% de hausse
sont très éloignés
de la baisse
de 43% préconisée
par le GIEC.
Il convient de noter
qu'un signal
a été envoyé, qu'une
prise de conscience
s'en est suivie.
Les négociations
qui ont eu cours
aux Emirats arabes unis
se sont conclues
par un accord historique.
L'accord a permis d'aboutir
à un texte important
qui dénonce de manière inédite
la responsabilité
des énergies fossiles,
et cet accord
a été signé
par les 196 pays
il y a quelques jours.
Nous pouvons
saluer
ce grand pas
en avant sur la confiance
entre les pays
de l'hémisphère nord
et de l'hémisphère sud.
Madame la ministre,
au regard des besoins
de financement
de cette transition,
qui nécessiterait entre 2000
et 2600 milliards d'euros
par an, quels engagements
la France prendra-t-elle
dans ses investissements majeurs?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à madame
Agnès Pannier-Runacher,
ministre de la Transition
énergétique.
- Agnès Pannier-Runacher:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le député
Anthony Brosse,
vous avez raison,
l'accord de la COP28
de Dubaï est historique.
Historique car il affirme
pour la première fois
depuis 30 ans la sortie
des énergies fossiles,
de toutes les énergies
fossiles,
dans un pays pétrolier.
La France et ses alliés
occidentaux n'ont rien lâché
jusqu'au bout de la négociation.
Historique
car il réaffirme la place
du nucléaire
pour la première fois
dans une COP.
Historique car il redit
l'importance
du renouvelable
et de l'efficacité énergétique.
Historique aussi
car il crée la confiance
avec les pays du sud
dans la suite
de toute l'action
du président
de la République,
qui a permis de retisser
ce fil de la confiance
et de créer
des accords avec 700
millions de dollars
pour les pays
les plus vulnérables,
100 milliards
de dollars apportés
chaque année pour les pays
en développement,
et toute l'action
que nous menons
pour obtenir
des financements innovants
pour accélérer
la transition énergétique.
Face au Rassemblement
National qui remet
en question
les analyses du GIEC
mais qui se précipite
dans le Pas-de-Calais lorsqu'il
y a des inondations,
ou face à l'inaction climatique
de la NUPES,
qui ne vote pas l'accélération
des énergies renouvelables,
nous agissons
en solidarité
avec les pays du sud
et en baissant
nos émissions de gaz
à effet de serre.
Sur les trois premiers
trimestres
de l'année,
nous les avons baissé
de 4,6%.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
S'il plaît, vraiment,
il faudrait
que le niveau sonore baisse.
On ne va pas
tenir
pendant toute la séance.
Merci à chacun
de faire un effort
pour écouter
le président Chassaigne
pour le groupe GDR.
- André Chassaigne:
Madame la présidente,
mes chers collègues,
madame la Première ministre,
après le rejet inédit
du projet de loi
sur l'immigration,
vous êtes sur le point
de commettre l'irréparable.
Depuis plusieurs jours,
les pires tractations
politiciennes ont lieu
dans le huis clos
de Matignon
et de l'Elysée,
au mépris de la séparation
des pouvoirs.
Vous instrumentalisez
la CMP pour contourner
le Parlement et conclure
coûte que coûte
avec la droite LR,
alignée sur les positions
du Rassemblement National.
Madame la Première
ministre, mesurez
bien votre responsabilité
historique.
L'élection du président
Macron devait
nous prémunir des pires
avanies du programme
de l'extrême droite.
Du bouclier, vous êtes devenu
le marchepied.
Comment pouvez-vous
ainsi céder
sur nos valeurs,
sur des questions aussi
essentielles que l'aide
médicale d'Etat,
le droit du sol,
le droit aux prestations sociales,
la déchéance de nationalité?
Mes chers collègues
de la majorité,
la seule position juste
est de tenir bon
sur le respect
des droits fondamentaux,
de refuser toute disposition
discriminatoire.
Mes chers
collègues,
ne succombez pas au fantasme
véhiculé
par l'extrême droite,
qui se délecte
de remporter une victoire
idéologique majeure.
Je vous le dis
solennellement,
vous allez écrire
ce soir une page
de notre histoire,
l'histoire d'un pays qui,
en ce 19 décembre,
renoncerait
à ses valeurs humanistes.
Madame la Première ministre,
mes chers collègues,
il est encore temps
de vous ressaisir.
N'ajoutez pas le déshonneur
s'associer
à la compromission!
Ne laissez pas ce texte
de la honte fracturer
de manière
durable
notre République et renier
les valeurs humanistes
de notre pays!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
Je vous remercie,
monsieur le président.
La parole est à madame
la Première ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Mesdames et messieurs
les députés, monsieur
le président
André Chassaigne,
j'ai beaucoup de respect
pour vous-même
et pour votre groupe,
mais je ne peux
pas laisser dire
n'importe quoi
sur le contenu de notre texte.
Je ne peux pas laisser
dire n'importe quoi.
En vous écoutant,
j'en viens à me demander
si vous avez lu
le texte
dont il est question.
Sortez des slogans
et des postures,
en voulant faire
l'amalgame
entre notre texte
et les positions
de l'extrême droite!
Les mots ont un sens,
monsieur le président!
L'extrême droite,
c'est le rejet
des étrangers
par principe,
parce qu'ils sont étrangers!
L'extrême droite,
c'est la préférence nationale!
Nous croyons
à l'intégration
par le travail!
Nous voulons
continuer à former
des talents et à diffuser
notre culture
en accueillant des étudiants
internationaux!
L'extrême droite...
L'extrême droite,
c'est le refus d'accueillir
ceux qui sont en danger,
le droit d'asile.
C'est en dehors de nos valeurs.
Ce qui est dans le texte,
c'est l'interdiction
de placer les mineurs
en rétention administrative.
C'est une mesure
forte, la gauche
ne l'a pas fait.
Ce qui est dans le texte,
c'est la régularisation
de celles
et ceux qui travaillent
sans avoir besoin
de l'accord de l'employeur.
La gauche ne l'a pas fait.
Ce qui est dans le texte,
ce sont des sanctions fermes
contre les passeurs,
contre les marchands
de sommeil qui profitent
des personnes fragiles.
La gauche ne l'a pas fait.
Monsieur le président
Chassaigne,
la NUPES est bien mal
placée pour faire
des procès en compromission
avec l'extrême droite.
C'est la NUPES
qui fait en permanence
des appels du pied
au Rassemblement National.
C'est la NUPES qui vote avec lui!
C'est la NUPES qui,
avec sa motion
de rejet, a bloqué
le débat, main
dans la main
avec le Rassemblement National!
Soyez clair!
Face à l'extrême
droite, la NUPES
est dans la collusion.
Nous, nous la combattons!
Avec le ministre
de l'Intérieur
et mon gouvernement,
nous défendons
ce projet de loi
car il est nécessaire!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Un peu de silence,
on entend rien!
S'il vous plaît!
- Elisabeth Borne:
Nous défendons
ce projet de loi
car il est efficace.
Nous défendons
ce projet de loi
car il est conforme
aux valeurs
que j'ai toujours portées,
aux valeurs portées
par le président
de la République
depuis 2017, aux valeurs
républicaines!
Applaudissements et huées
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie,
madame la Première ministre.
Mes chers collègues,
vraiment,
ça ne va pas être possible
de continuer
comme ça.
Vous posez les questions
et vous hurlez
pendant les réponses,
ce n'est pas possible.
C'est une séance de questions
au gouvernement.
Huées
Monsieur Guedj...
On redescend
la pression, s'il
vous plaît.
Monsieur Bilde
pour le Rassemblement National.
- Bruno Bilde: Merci,
madame la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à madame
la Première ministre.
Personne n'est épargné
par la vie chère:
femme, homme, famille,
salarié, étudiant
et retraité.
En 2023, l'inflation
cumulée atteint 20%.
Tous les prix s'envolent.
En un an, le simple
kilo de pommes
de terre congelées
a augmenté de 25%.
Dans cinq jours,
nous fêterons Noël.
Fêter Noël en famille
est désormais
un luxe pour beaucoup de Français.
37% d'entre
eux redoutent
de ne pas pouvoir
offrir un cadeau
à leurs proches.
Les associations font
face à une explosion
des demandeurs
d'aide alimentaire
chaque trimestre.
30% de nouvelles personnes
poussent
les portes des structures
d'aide alimentaire
tous les trimestres.
Hier, j'ai rencontré
les responsables
de la Banque alimentaire.
Ils sont débordés.
Votre gouvernement affirme
que les Français
ne s'appauvrissent pas.
Les chiffres
sont pourtant accablants.
Les femmes représentent
près de 60%
des personnes accueillies
par le Secours Catholique,
ce qui pousse
l'association à parler
de féminisation
de la pauvreté
dans son dernier rapport annuel.
Deux millions de salariés
pauvres n'arrivent
plus à vivre dignement
de leur travail.
Un quart des enfants
sont désormais
en situation de pauvreté.
Les retraités
souffrent autant,
si bien
qu'ils représentent 27%
des ménages pauvres.
Les Français
ne vous demandent pas l'aumône
mais ils souhaitent
vivre dignement
sans être poussés
à la pauvreté
par la vie chère.
Il faut réformer
les règles européennes
de fixation des prix
de l'électricité.
Il faut baisser la TVA
sur les énergies
et produits de première nécessité!
Vous ne faites rien,
absolument rien!
Madame la Première ministre,
quand allez-vous enfin défendre
les Français?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à madame
Olivia Grégoire,
ministre en charge des Petites
et moyennes entreprises,
du Commerce, de l'Artisanat
et du Tourisme.
- Olivia Grégoire:
Merci, monsieur
le député Bruno Bilde,
je me demande
si consigne a été
passée aux 88 députés
du Rassemblement
National de poser
chaque semaine la même question.
Ca vous permet
de cocher des cases tel
un bingo!
On va vous rappeler des évidences.
Vous ne voulez pas
les entendre
mais je vais les rappeler.
Vous parlez de baisser
la TVA, toujours
la même rengaine.
On va regarder
ensemble,
quel est le niveau
de la TVA alimentaire
en Espagne?
9,2%.
Quel est le niveau
de l'inflation alimentaire ici
grâce à l'action du gouvernement?
7,6% en huit mois.
On a perdu 8 points
d'inflation alimentaire.
Que se passe-t-il en Espagne?
Ils ont perdu 2
milliards d'euros
et ils ont 2%
d'inflation alimentaire
en plus.
Vos leçons,
vous devriez les réviser!
La baisse de la TVA
que vous invoquez
est injuste,
qu'on soit pauvre
ou qu'on soit riche.
On est concerné de la même façon.
La baisse de la TVA
est inefficace,
l'Espagne l'a démontré.
La baisse de la TVA
coûte une fortune,
des milliards
au budget public,
pour aucun résultat.
La nouvelle année
arrivant, je formule
un voeu un peu fou,
le voeu que peut-être,
un jour, vous vous mettiez
à travailler
et à proposer
des vraies mesures
pour accompagner les Français.
En attendant,
cette majorité,
avec le bouclier
énergie
et avec le bouclier
tarifaire,
avec les renégociations
commerciales,
a baissé l'inflation
alimentaire
de 8 points en huit mois.
Une bien belle année!
Mettez-vous à travailler!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Graziella Melchior
pour le groupe Renaissance.
- Graziella Melchior: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse
à Gabriel Attal,
ministre de l'Education
nationale
et de la Jeunesse.
Cette année 2023
a été marquée
par de nombreux phénomènes
climatiques exceptionnels,
des records de chaleur
battus mois
après mois,
des épisodes caniculaires
plus longs
et plus récurrents,
et des tempêtes toujours
plus dévastatrices,
comme Ciaran,
qui a frappé le Finistère.
L'école peut et doit devenir
le premier lieu d'engagement
pour la transition écologique.
Les élèves, les enseignants
et les personnels
ont tout leur rôle.
Ces convictions,
ce sont celles
nous partageons dans mon groupe.
Nous avons cinq grands
axes
dans un texte que je défends.
Nous avons formulé
109 préconisations
pour adapter l'école
aux enjeux climatiques.
Cet objectif, je sais
que vous le partagez,
comme en témoigne
le plan ambitieux
que vous portez
conjointement
avec le ministre Christophe Béchu.
Ce plan prévoit en effet
de rénover 40.000 écoles
en 10 ans.
Cela pose plusieurs
questions, et afin
de mieux accompagner
les élus, notamment
ceux des petites communes,
nous formulons plusieurs
propositions,
comme la création
d'un guichet unique
en préfecture
ou le lancement d'un plan
pour développer
les cours végétalisés.
Nous sommes convaincus
que la végétalisation
des cours constitue
un levier essentiel
pour faire baisser
la température
dans les écoles
et pour sensibiliser
les enfants à la protection
de la biodiversité.
Aussi, pouvez-vous
nous préciser l'ampleur
du plan et nous indiquer
de quelle manière
nous pourrons demain
mieux accompagner
les élus locaux afin
que nos écoles soient exemplaires
dans l'adaptation
aux enjeux climatiques?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Gabriel Attal, ministre
de l'Education nationale
et de la Jeunesse.
- Gabriel Attal:
Merci, madame la présidente.
Madame la députée
Graziella Melchior,
l'isolation thermique
de nos écoles,
de nos collèges
et de nos lycées
est une absolue nécessité.
C'est absolument
nécessaire d'abord
pour les conditions
de travail
de nos enseignants
et les conditions d'apprentissage
de nos enfants.
On n'apprend pas bien
dans une école
où il fait
trop chaud l'été
et trop froid l'hiver.
C'est aussi
absolument essentiel
pour atteindre nos objectifs
de la stratégie
nationale bas carbone.
L'isolation thermique
des bâtiments publics
et des établissements
scolaires
est absolument nécessaire
pour atteindre
nos objectifs en matière
de stratégie nationale bas
carbone.
Ce que nous avons mis
en place
après l'engagement
du président
de la République,
c'est le plus grand plan
de rénovation scolaire
de l'histoire
de notre pays.
500 millions d'euros
par an à compter
de 2024 qui vont nous permettre
de rénover 40.000 écoles
sur 10 ans.
Ces dernières années,
on rénovait
en moyenne un millier
d'écoles par an.
En 2024, ce sera 2000 écoles.
Nous serons à 4000
écoles rénovées
grâce à l'engagement
de cette majorité
et aux crédits
qui se sont débloqués,
500 millions d'euros par an.
Je voulais vous remercier
pour le rapport
que vous nous avez remis
et sur lequel
vous avez travaillé.
Il nous permet de parfaire
l'organisation
que nous avons présentée
avec Christophe Béchu
pour que ces fonds
puissent
être bien utilisés.
Il faut
prioriser là
où on en a le plus besoin.
On a besoin de diagnostic
et d'orienter
vers ceux qui en
ont le plus besoin.
Vous parlez du guichet unique.
Il faut un guichet unique
dans les préfectures.
C'est ce que nous sommes
en train de mettre
en place.
Sur les îlots
de fraîcheur
dans les écoles,
nous y sommes favorables
et nous accompagnerons
les collectivités locales
qui s'engageront dans cette voie.
40.000 écoles rénovées
dans les 10 ans
qui viennent,
c'est du jamais vu
dans l'histoire de notre pays.
Nous pouvons être fiers
de cet engagement.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Hervé Saulignac
pour le groupe socialiste.
- Hervé Saulignac:
Madame la Première ministre,
vous nous avez fait la leçon
la semaine dernière
pour une motion
de rejet adoptée
avec des voix de l'extrême droite.
Vous voilà en position
de faire adopter
une loi avec les voix
de l'extrême droite
et avec ses applaudissements.
Ce ne sont pas
des concessions
qui sont faites
à la droite
la plus dure.
Ce sont des compromissions,
des enjeux
de transactions
sur fond de renoncement
qui enterre définitivement
le macronisme originel.
L'objet même de ce texte
vous a échappé:
la question
migratoire n'est
plus un sujet.
Le seul sujet pour vous,
c'est de trouver
une majorité, et peu
importe le prix
à payer,
puisque la préférence
nationale irrigue
déjà le texte
qui est en train de se préparer.
La CMP, qui se déroule
en ce moment même,
ne relève
plus de la fabrique
de la loi.
C'est le congrès
des petits arrangements,
où la fin qui justifie les moyens.
Vous redoutez qu'un échec
sur ce texte signe
la fin de votre quinquennat.
Je vous le dis,
une adoption sera
de toute façon
une victoire à la Pyrus.
Oui, l'extrême droite
sera triomphante.
Cette séquence
prend des allures
de naufrage politique
et parlementaire.
Chers collègues
de la majorité,
je m'adresse
à vous avec respect
et solennité.
Je vous dis
qu'il est encore temps
de faire obstacle à ce texte.
Chacun d'entre
vous a rendez-vous
dans quelques heures
avec sa conscience.
Je vous dis
tranquillement
que votre responsabilité n'a
jamais été aussi grande,
que piétiner
sa conscience, ça finit
par faire mal, que l'histoire
retient toujours
le nom des braves,
jamais celui
de ceux qui ont failli.
Gaullistes, humanistes,
progressistes,
ne renoncez pas!
Soyez à la hauteur
de l'histoire
qui s'inscrit dans ces heures!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Gérald Darmanin,
ministre de l'Intérieur
et des Outre-mer.
- Gérald Darmanin:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le député,
venant d'un parti
dont le président
a proposé la déchéance
de nationalité,
votre question
ne manque pas de sel.
Vous essayez
de vous rattraper du pacte
que vous avez mené
avec le Rassemblement National.
La vérité,
c'est que vous n'osez
pas dire
que vous n'avez pas voulu
discuter du texte
pendant 15 jours!
La vérité,
ce que vous n'osez pas dire
qu'à l'Assemblée
nationale,
vous avez été battu
très largement
et que vous avez eu peur du débat.
La vérité,
c'est que vous trouvez
aujourd'hui des excuses
pour expliquer l'inexplicable.
Vous vous êtes levé
comme un seul homme
avec le parti
de madame Le Pen
pour pouvoir
applaudir
pour quelques instants!
Monsieur le député,
pour la première fois,
puisque la CMP vient
d'être conclusive,
la loi de la République
va permettre
d'avoir des régularisations.
Même François
Mitterrand
n'avait pas mis dans la loi
les régularisations
des métiers en tension.
Pour la première fois,
nous allons interdire
à des mineurs
d'être dans des centres
de rétention administrative.
Nous allons offrir
à tous les étrangers
des cours de français
gratuitement
et obliger l'employeur
à pouvoir prendre
ces cours pendant les heures
de travail!
Nous allons offrir
des titres de séjour
aux gens qui dénoncent
ces marchands
de sommeil
et sanctionner
ce que vous n'avez
jamais fait:
les employeurs qui organisent
des filières d'immigration
illégale!
Vous n'êtes
jamais là
pour être ceux
qui accompagnent
les policiers et les gendarmes.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Jean-Charles Larsonneur
pour le groupe Horizon.
- Jean-Charles Larsonneur:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
Sébastien Lecornu.
L'Assemblée se déchire
et nous dansons
sur un volcan.
La situation
est difficile en Ukraine.
Il y a la guerre à Gaza,
et des attaques
en mer Rouge.
C'est sur cette dernière
situation
que je souhaite évoquer.
Le canal de Suez
et la colonne vertébrale
des échanges
entre l'Europe et l'Asie.
Nos marins sont en danger.
Les grands armateurs,
sensibles
à la sécurité
de leurs équipages,
ont annoncé suspendre
jusqu'à nouvel ordre
le franchissement
du canal de Suez.
Tous les grands armateurs
représentent près
de 60% du trafic
mondial de containers.
Le contournement,
ajouté à la hausse
du baril, font peser
de vraies inquiétudes
sur l'économie européenne.
Le 9 décembre,
une riposte à des attaques
de drones en provenance
des côtes
du Yémen a eu lieu.
Hier, en Israël,
le secrétaire d'Etat
à la Défense a annoncé
la création d'une opération
en coalition
pour assurer la liberté
de navigation dans la zone.
Comment la France
entend-elle réagir
et contribuer
au rétablissement
de la sécurité dans la zone?
Quelle articulation
proposez-vous
avec des opérations
internationales
et européennes déjà en cours?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à monsieur Sébastien Lecornu.
- Sébastien Lecornu:
Monsieur le député,
j'aimerais déjà,
au nom du gouvernement
et au nom de la représentation
nationale, rendre hommage
à nos soldats
de la Marine nationale,
de l'armée de l'air
de l'armée de terre
qui rendent actuellement
leur mission
dans des conditions
particulièrement difficiles.
Il y a la présence
d'un contingent
de soldats français
dans la région.
Il y a aussi l'action
de la Marine nationale
pour la liberté de circulation.
Sur l'ensemble de ces bancs,
nous devons évidemment
se mobiliser.
La France est déjà
largement présente
dans cette région.
La mission
qui est une mission de lutte
contre la piraterie
maritime,
qui n'est pas tout à fait
l'objet
des menaces de sécurité
que nous connaissons, aujourd'hui.
Les projections
de notre groupe aéronaval,
la frégate Languedoc
a dû ouvrir
le feu
il y a plusieurs jours
de cela pour défendre un bateau.
Les grandes
compagnies maritimes
sont inquiètes.
Nous devons
avoir une stratégie
pour ce faire.
L'initiative américaine
est intéressante.
Elle permet d'optimiser
et de partager
les différents
renseignements et options
sur l'ensemble de la région.
On rappelle aussi
les propositions
du président
de la République
sur les conditions
que nous devons développer
contre les différentes
menaces
que la région peut donner.
Le ministre de la Défense
d'Arabie saoudite sera
ce soir à Paris.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Monsieur le député?
- Jean-Charles
Larsonneur: Merci
pour les militaires,
je veux
avoir une pensée pour Djibouti,
un partenaire important
qui souffre de la situation.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à madame Géraldine Grangier.
- Géraldine Grangier:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Mes chers collègues,
cette question s'adresse
à madame la Première ministre.
1,5 milliard d'euros,
voici la somme dépensée
par les départements
français pour l'accueil
des mineurs non accompagnés.
Cette somme vous a été
rappelée à Strasbourg
lors du congrès réunissant
les départements
de France.
Nous le savons,
les départements assument
la quasi-totalité
de la charge financière
de la mission d'accueil
et d'évaluation
de ces mineurs,
qui vient s'ajouter
aux dépenses sociales
envers nos compatriotes
les plus fragiles.
C'est le cri
d'alarme lancé
par les départements que je veux
porter aujourd'hui.
Vous l'avez entendu comme moi,
les départements
sont dans l'incapacité
d'absorber
la hausse continue
du nombre de personnes
qui se présentent
comme mineurs
non accompagnés
et d'en assumer seule
le coût financier.
Mon département fait face
à un flux migratoire
sans précédent.
Sa présidente alerte
face à la hausse
de ces mineurs.
Ils sont près
d'un millier aujourd'hui.
Les dispositifs d'accueil
sont déjà saturés
par une hausse d'enfants confiés.
Les départements sont asphyxiés.
Madame la Première
ministre, l'argent
que les départements
consacrent
aux mineurs non
accompagnés,
c'est de l'argent
en moins pour la protection
de l'enfance, notamment.
J'en veux pour preuve
des dysfonctionnements graves
à la maison Victor Hugo.
La surcharge
de travail cumulée
à la difficulté
de l'accueil d'enfants
en grande détresse
psychologique a conduit
six éducateurs
sur sept à l'arrêt maladie.
La nuit, ce sont des cris
et des hurlements
qui expriment
la détresse de chacun.
Quand est-ce que l'Etat
assumera totalement
le coût de l'accueil
de ces personnes?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à madame Charlotte Caubel.
- Charlotte Caubel: Merci.
Nous partageons
avec vous le constat
que la protection
de l'enfance est aujourd'hui
en tension.
Nous partageons
le constat
qu'il y a une reprise
des flux migratoires
qui vient évidemment
complexifier
la situation de la protection
de l'enfance.
Non,
nous ne partageons pas la même
valeur, un enfant,
quel qu'il soit,
qu'il soit français
ou étranger,
en situation d'isolement
sur notre territoire,
est un enfant en danger.
Il doit être protégé.
Nous ne partageons pas
non plus votre constat
sur ce que fait le gouvernement.
Depuis 2016,
cette majorité a fait
en sorte d'améliorer
l'évaluation
de la minorité,
pour écarter les personnes
se prétendant
mineures
et qui ne sont pas mineures.
Le gouvernement
et cette majorité
a voté des dispositifs
pour faciliter
la prise en charge
des mineurs,
pour apporter
un soutien financier
du gouvernement.
La Première
ministre a entendu
il y a quelques semaines
le cri d'alerte
des départements.
Elle a augmenté l'enveloppe
du gouvernement
au soutien des départements.
Les départements
interrogés ont manifesté
leur souhait de garder
cette compétence,
et ils nous ont demandé
de travailler
le dispositif pour l'améliorer.
Nous l'avons fait
en mettant en place
il y a une semaine
et demi un groupe
de travail
pour améliorer
encore le dispositif
et notamment accélérer
les recours,
et accélérer la mise
à l'abri des mineurs.
Madame la députée,
ça fait depuis 2016
que le gouvernement
est engagé auprès
des départements
pour assurer ce respect.
Un mineur, qu'il soit français
ou étranger, lorsqu'il
est isolé,
est en danger et doit
être protégé.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Benjamin Lucas.
- Benjamin Lucas:
Merci, madame la présidente.
Il est des moments
où il se joue ici
bien
plus que de la politique,
bien plus que la loi.
Alors que l'extrême droite
vient d'annoncer
avoir engrangé une victoire
idéologique majeure
et s'apprête
à voter votre texte
sur l'immigration,
je ne peux pas,
je ne veux pas croire,
chers collègues,
de la majorité
présidentielle,
que vous puissiez
toutes et tous cautionner
ce qui a été fait
sous la dictée
du gouvernement en commission
mixte paritaire.
Retour de la préférence nationale.
Fin de l'automaticité
du droit du sol.
Quotas.
Restriction
au regroupement familial.
Abandon des régularisations
par le travail.
Volonté de réformer
l'aide médicale d'Etat
en 2024.
Vous avez cédé sur tout.
Le sujet, en cet
instant, ce n'est
plus la gauche,
ce n'est plus la droite,
ce n'est plus la majorité,
ce n'est
plus l'opposition,
c'est le serment humaniste,
conclu avec les Françaises
et les Français
en 2017 et en 2022.
Quand des millions
d'entre eux ont choisi
de faire barrage
à l'extrême droite raciste
dans notre pays.
Soyons collectivement
digne de la dignité
des Français!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Gérald Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin:
Monsieur le député,
madame la présidente,
ça vous faisait
moins de peine la semaine
dernière lorsque
le Rassemblement
National se levait
pour vous applaudir.
Monsieur Lucas,
en plus d'aller chercher
les voix du Front National,
vous mentez!
Dans le texte
de la CMP,
il y a bien la régularisation
des travailleurs
des métiers en tension!
Vous mentez
parce qu'il y a bien
la fin des mineurs
dans les centres
de rétention!
Monsieur Lucas, les sénateurs
du Rassemblement National
ont voté contre le texte
du Sénat
il y a 15 jours.
Madame Le Pen viendrait
courir au secours
de la victoire aujourd'hui?
C'est pour voir
votre mine déconfite
en ayant voté la motion de rejet!
Nous prenons nos responsabilités.
N'inventez pas n'importe quoi.
Grâce à l'action
de la Première ministre
et de la majorité,
il y a des distinctions
entre les personnes
qui travaillent
et les personnes
qui ne travaillent pas.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Monsieur le député?
- Benjamin Lucas:
Vous êtes lamentable.
Nous n'avons pas de leçon
à recevoir
de la part
de ceux qui font entrer
du pan entier du programme
de Jean-Marie
Le Pen dans la loi!
Nous n'avons pas de leçon
à recevoir
de ceux qui offrent
une victoire historique
à l'extrême droite!
Rien ne vous obligeait
à convoquer
une CMP!
Rien ne vous obligeait
à présenter
ce texte rejeté
par l'Assemblée nationale!
L'histoire vous jugera sévèrement!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
- Gérald Darmanin:
Monsieur Lucas...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
S'il vous plaît.
- Gérald Darmanin:
Nous nous connaissons peu.
Moi, je n'ai pas quitté
la région
où le Front National
était pour me faire élire
ailleurs.
J'ai toujours battu
le Front National!
Je n'ai pas quitté la région
des Hauts-de-France
pour me présenter
en Ile-de-France!
J'ai battu
le Front National
a toutes les élections!
Vos leçons de morale
républicaine,
je les mets dans ma poche.
Vous avez renoncé
à parler au peuple
de gauche
pour les protéger
et nous leurs éviterons
le Front National!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à monsieur Jean-Marc Zulesi.
- Jean-Marc Zulesi:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à madame
Agnès Pannier-Runacher.
L'urgence climatique
est au coeur
de notre action.
Nous luttons
contre cette urgence climatique
par des actions pragmatiques,
en particulier
en matière de transports.
Nous agissons
pour des bonus écologiques.
Pour des primes
à la conversion
qui permettent
d'avoir une politique ambitieuse.
La semaine dernière,
nous avons porté
une mesure importante
en matière d'écologie,
le leasing social,
la voiture
à moins de 100 euros.
Ce dispositif permettra
à nos concitoyens
les plus modestes d'accéder
à un véhicule électrique
à moins de 100 euros.
Ces véhicules circuleront
dès l'année prochaine.
Ils concerneront
des véhicules français
et européens.
C'est un pas
de plus vers la fin
de l'utilisation
des énergies fossiles.
Nous apportons
des solutions concrètes
aux citoyens.
Une écologie populaire,
une écologie
des territoires.
C'est aussi un sujet
de souveraineté industrielle
parce que c'est une chance
pour notre industrie.
Nous donnons priorité
à l'industrie française
pour décarboner nos transports.
Il faut aller plus loin.
Madame
la ministre,
quelles sont les perspectives
pour pacifier
le dispositif et faire
que les transports décarbonés
soient accessibles à tous
les concitoyens?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à madame Agnès
Pannier-Runacher.
- Agnès Pannier-Runacher:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Avec le président
de la République
et la Première
ministre,
nous nous sommes engagés
à accompagner
les Français
avec des solutions concrètes
pour la transition énergétique.
La transition énergétique
que nous portons
est une transition
juste, qui répond
aux besoins de chacun
des Français.
C'est ce que nous faisons
avec le leasing social.
C'est cette solution
qui permet
d'avoir un véhicule
à 100 euros
par mois, un véhicule
électrique,
de 50 à 150 euros
selon les modèles choisis.
Il est une promesse
de campagne du président
de la République.
Une promesse de campagne
que nous mettons
en oeuvre,
une promesse de campagne
qui est bonne
pour le climat,
bonne pour le portefeuille
et le pouvoir d'achat
des Français.
Et bonne
pour notre emploi
et notre industrie.
Bonne pour le climat
parce que le véhicule électrique,
c'est deux à cinq fois
moins d'émissions
de CO2.
C'est aussi moins cher qu'une
voiture thermique.
C'est aussi bon
pour l'industrie
et l'emploi.
Seuls les modèles
qui ont une empreinte vertueuse
seront retenus.
Des modèles
fabriqués en France
et en Europe.
Qui pourra en bénéficier?
50% des Français
pourront y avoir accès,
à condition qu'ils remplissent
une deuxième condition,
qui est de faire 15
kilomètres le matin
et le soir pour aller
au travail,
soit de faire 8000 kilomètres
pour travailler lorsqu'ils
sont par exemple
aide à domicile
ou aide-soignante.
Pour eux, en janvier,
la plate-forme ouvrira
et vous pouvez
compter sur moi
pour que les 25.000 premiers
véhicules soient augmentés
avec les constructeurs.
C'est une mesure
pour les Français,
pour les classes populaires
et les classes moyennes.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à monsieur Eric Coquerel.
- Eric Coquerel: Merci.
Cette question
est à madame la ministre
des Affaires étrangères.
Je vais d'abord rendre
hommage à cet homme
qui travaillait
pour la diplomatie française,
qui est mort
sous les bombardements,
et auquel
nous n'avons pas donné
de minute de silence.
Je veux penser
à notre compatriote mort,
ainsi qu'aux otages morts
qui ont connu
le même sort que plus de 16.000
palestiniens tués
depuis le 7 octobre
par l'armée israélienne.
Qui peut douter
des véritables objectifs
de guerre du gouvernement
israélien?
Ils bombardent
le sud de la bande
de Gaza.
Ils veulent
en finir avec Gaza
et la Cisjordanie.
Vous avez été la première
de l'exécutif
à avoir appelé
à un cessez-le-feu
que nous portons depuis le départ!
Vous allez plus loin!
Après la mort d'une personne
de la diplomatie,
vous avez dit cela.
Je regrette qu'il ait
fallu ce drame
pour condamner ce genre
de bombardement.
Les bombardements israéliens
ciblent expressément
les Palestiniens.
Depuis la colonisation
sur la Cisjordanie,
vous avez dit
qu'en Cisjordanie,
la construction
de colonies s'accélérait
en violation flagrante
du droit international.
Vous avez aussi parlé
des exactions commises
par les colons israéliens.
Vous parlez
de mesures à prendre
et vous avez raison!
Comment passer
de la parole aux actes?
Peut-on se contenter d'un appel
au cessez-le-feu lorsque l'ONU
parle de nettoyage ethnique
et de risque génocidaire?
N'est-il pas temps
de reconnaître
un Etat palestinien
et de porter
le déploiement d'une
force d'interposition
de l'ONU?
N'est-il pas temps de prendre
des sanctions économiques
à l'encontre d'Israël
pour faire cesser
ce carnage?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à madame
Catherine Colonna.
- Catherine Colonna:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le député,
monsieur le président.
J'étais au Proche-Orient
dimanche
et lundi.
En Israël et à Ramallah,
auprès de l'Autorité palestinienne
dimanche.
A Beyrouth hier.
Il est possible
d'être solidaire
à la fois des Israéliens
et des Palestiniens.
En Israël,
en plus des entretiens
politiques, je me suis rendue
au centre d'identification
des victimes
des attentats terroristes
du 7 octobre.
La réalité,
monsieur le député,
est glaçante.
C'est celle d'une
barbarie sans nom,
qui a visé beaucoup de femmes,
sinon principalement
des femmes.
Mutilées, défigurées,
presque toutes.
Rien ne justifie jamais cela.
Rien ne justifie
jamais le terrorisme.
N'oublions pas le 7 octobre.
J'ai dit aussi
que trop de civils meurent
à Gaza.
Cela ne peut pas continuer ainsi.
Ce message s'adresse
à Israël, évidemment.
J'ai rencontré des Palestiniens
victimes d'exactions
et de menaces de colons
extrémistes israéliens.
Ces colons qui provoquent
des violences
et commettent des exactions
inacceptables.
Je l'ai dit.
La France
ne restera pas silencieuse.
Elle prendra des mesures
à titre national.
Ce travail est en cours.
Nous demandons
à Israël de faire
toute la lumière sur ces actes
mais de prendre des mesures
car le climat d'impunité
qui règne encourage ces exactions.
Ces terres sont palestiniennes.
Elles feront partie
d'un Etat palestinien.
Nous le savons tous,
seule la solution
à deux Etats peut
amener la paix
et la sécurité pour tous.
C'est notre objectif.
C'est aussi le vôtre.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Eric Pauget.
- Eric Pauget: Merci.
Madame la ministre,
en décembre 2017,
le président
de la République promettait
de ne plus voir
personne dans la rue
et d'apporter d'ici la fin
de son premier quinquennat
un toit
à toutes celles
et ceux qui sont sans abri.
Malheureusement,
six ans après, pauvreté
et grande précarité s'aggravent.
Selon un récent rapport
du Secours Catholique,
le nombre
de personnes vivant
sous le seuil
de pauvreté atteint
un triste record
à plus de 9 millions
de personnes concernées.
La plupart
ne dispose
que de moins de 800 euros.
La situation est dramatique.
L'inflation alimentaire
et énergétique,
les inégalités de santé,
le dérèglement climatique
fragilisent les plus précaires
jusqu'aux travailleurs pauvres.
L'action des bénévoles
des associations
sont elles-mêmes touchées.
Elles sont à bout de souffle.
Dans ma ville,
Croix-Rouge, Restos du Coeur,
et leurs bénévoles
sonnent l'alarme.
Leurs charges ont augmenté de 15%.
Elles ne peuvent
plus répondre aux 25%
de demandes supplémentaires.
Le sujet ne peut
plus s'accommoder
du "En même temps".
De nouvelles
solidarités doivent
être mises en oeuvre.
Je pense notamment
à une réduction d'impôt
de 100% applicable
aux versements
des dons à destination
des associations caritatives.
Le chantier est urgent et décisif.
Allez-vous, contre le fléau
de la grande précarité,
agir de façon forte et déterminée?
Allez-vous mettre en place
cette proposition?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à madame
Aurore Bergé.
- Aurore Bergé: Merci.
Monsieur le député,
vous avez évidemment raison
sur la situation
qui est extrêmement difficile,
trop difficile
pour de nombreux Français.
C'est la raison
pour laquelle nous agissons.
Il n'y
a pas de procrastination
en la matière.
Il y a la nécessité
d'agir, d'abord
en direct au bénéfice
des personnes
qui sont concernées,
par la pauvreté,
par le risque
de l'isolement social
et de l'exclusion.
C'est ce qu'on fait
avec le plan
de lutte
contre la pauvreté
avec les collectivités
locales,
les départements,
et les métropoles.
C'est une démarche
de partenariat
pour juguler la pauvreté.
Ce que nous avons renforcé,
nous l'avons présenté
avec la Première ministre.
20 milliards
d'euros mobilisés
sur ce quinquennat.
La lutte contre la pauvreté,
c'est d'abord l'insertion
professionnelle.
La dignité se retrouve
dans l'emploi
et dans l'insertion
professionnelle.
C'est la question
des luttes
contre les difficultés
objectives
à retrouver un emploi,
comme les modes
de garde
pour les enfants,
et c'est un soutien
très renforcé
pour les enfants.
Il y a évidemment
les associations
dont vous parlez.
Non seulement nous avons augmenté
considérablement
les moyens sur l'aide
alimentaire,
de 156 millions à 185 millions.
Nous avons fait
évoluer le dispositif
qui permet d'avoir une réduction
fiscale jusqu'à 1000 euros.
Ca permet
d'avoir plus de donateurs.
Les associations,
c'est maintenant
qu'elles ont besoin
de nous, de l'Etat,
des collectivités et des citoyens.
L'essentiel
de leurs récoltes,
c'est en décembre.
Il y a ce que nous faisons
en tant que citoyens.
Je sais que les citoyens
sauront y répondre
avec générosité.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
- Eric Pauget:
Merci de vos réponses.
Je pense qu'il faut
que l'on travaille
le couple maires-associations.
C'est une priorité.
Il faut le faire
dans les villages,
dans les villes
et dans les communes.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à monsieur
Guillaume Vuilletet.
- Guillaume Vuilletet:
Ma question s'adresse
à monsieur Clément Beaune,
ministre chargé
des Transports.
Dans six mois, notre pays
et l'agglomération parisienne
en particulier accueilleront
les Jeux Olympiques.
Ils seront au centre
de l'attention
du monde entier.
Je suis convaincu
que chacun a à coeur
la réussite de ces Jeux.
Il n'y a pas d'autres
options
que de le réussir.
Je veux saluer le travail
de votre collègue,
Amélie Oudéa-Castéra.
Je me réjouis,
en saluant avec respect
les détracteurs,
que le décret ait été publié
sans polémique.
Pour garantir
la sécurité des Jeux,
vous avez une responsabilité
immense,
celle d'assurer
le bon fonctionnement
des transports.
La Coupe du Monde
de rugby a été
une réussite sur tous les plans.
Nous pouvons en être fiers.
Les Jeux Olympiques
seront toutefois
une échelle autrement
plus importante.
Ce sont des millions de visiteurs,
touristes, athlètes,
médias, qui vont devoir
se déplacer
dans la région
et dans tout le pays,
sur des territoires
qui devront
tout de même continuer
à fonctionner.
Il se dit
que nous ne serions pas prêts.
La maire de Paris
a dit qu'il n'y
aurait pas la fréquence
nécessaire
en l'été 2024
en précisant qu'il aurait
des difficultés avec le RER
de la Porte Maillot.
Je vous avoue
que nombre de salariés
de ma circonscription
se demandent comment
tout cela va se passer.
Alors que 15 millions
de visiteurs
sont attendus,
dans une région
qui ne peut pas
et ne doit pas s'arrêter
de vivre, pouvez-vous
nous détailler
les mesures qui seront
prises et mises
en oeuvre pour éviter
un confinement olympique,
en un mot, pour réussir
ce challenge
et permettre à tous
de se déplacer
au mieux pendant les Jeux
Olympiques?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole
est à monsieur Clément Beaune.
- Clément Beaune:
Monsieur le député,
vous relayez un certain nombre
d'interrogations parfaitement
légitimes de nos concitoyens,
y compris
dans votre circonscription.
Vous ne le relayez pas
mais vous relevez certaines
polémiques
que nous allons démentir.
Je retrouverai
un comité des mobilités
pour faire le point
sur l'avancement
de tous les chantiers,
accessibilité,
les infrastructures,
services offerts
aux Franciliens
et au monde entier.
C'est un honneur,
une fierté, pour Paris
et l'Ile-de-France,
d'accueillir
après une centaine d'années,
les Jeux Olympiques d'été.
Nous ferons
tout pour réussir ce défi
qui sera d'abord
un défi de transport.
C'est la plus grande
opération de transport
que notre pays a connu.
800.000 personnes
par jour
en plus dans les transports
publics.
13 millions de visiteurs.
Nous avons pris
un engagement inédit,
qu'aucune ville n'avait
pris avant Paris
et la France.
C'est 100% des sites pour 100%
des spectateurs,
qui soient desservis
en transports publics.
Nous le réussirons.
Nous augmentons
l'offre de transport
de 15% pour que pendant les Jeux
Olympiques,
tout le monde puisse
y avoir accès.
Il est hors
de question
d'avoir je ne sais
quel confinement olympique,
d'empêcher les Parisiens
de circuler,
qui veulent
travailler et mener
leur vie comme ils l'entendent.
Il y aura des mesures de sécurité,
d'organisation,
nous les mettons
en oeuvre avec la ville
de Paris, avec la région,
pour limiter
le plus possible les impacts
de la vie quotidienne
des Français et des Franciliens.
C'est cela qui devrait
nous réunir plutôt
que des polémiques stériles.
Les Jeux Olympiques
sont un accélérateur
de l'investissement
dans les transports publics.
Sans ça,
nous ne serions pas au rendez-vous
pour prolonger
la ligne 14
pour des millions
de personnes,
pour le RER, pour les taxis
qui seront accessibles
aux personnes à mobilité réduite.
C'est un formidable
héritage
pour notre ville,
notre capital
et notre pays.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Laurent Alexandre.
- Laurent Alexandre:
Monsieur le ministre
de la Santé,
les professionnels soignants
ne cessent d'alerter
sur la dégradation
de leurs conditions
d'exercice
sur les inégalités
de santé en France.
Inégalités sociales,
avec 13 ans d'écart d'espérance
de vie
entre les plus riches
et les plus pauvres.
Inégalités
territoriales,
avec deux ans
d'espérance de vie
en moins pour les habitants
des zones rurales.
La désertification
médicale
est une réalité.
15% des Aveyronnais
n'ont pas de médecin traitant.
Dans l'hôpital public,
on est proche
de l'effondrement.
Les urgences doivent
garantir une égalité
de traitement
pour les populations.
Or, dans certains
hôpitaux, les urgences
sont régulées
depuis l'application
de la loi.
Concrètement, tout patient,
tout professionnel
de santé est obligé
de joindre
le 15 avant de se déplacer
ou d'orienter
un patient aux urgences.
Certains sont renvoyés
vers un autre hôpital situé
à plus de 45 minutes.
Cela génère
des angoissés et met
en danger les patients.
Le système devait
être provisoire
mais il s'installe.
Les urgences pourraient
être complètement fermées certains
jours.
Le personnel est écoeuré
de ne pouvoir faire
son travail
correctement en raison
du retrait de l'Etat.
Ils sont épuisés.
Jusqu'à quand tiendront-ils?
Des médecins exerçant
dans notre pays seraient
contraints de raccrocher en début
d'année prochaine
en raison de manque de postes.
Vous stigmatisez
les travailleurs étrangers
qui participent
à faire tenir
notre pays debout
et vous vider
nos hôpitaux
de leur médecin
alors que la situation
est proche
du chaos!
Ecoutez nos propositions
de bon sens.
Saisissez-vous
de la proposition
de loi transpartisane qui vise
à réguler l'installation
des médecins
pour lutter
contre les déserts médicaux.
Allez-vous enfin agir
pour garantir l'égalité d'accès
à la santé?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Aurélien Rousseau.
- Aurélien Rousseau:
Monsieur le député,
le centre hospitalier
Pierre Delpech
dont vous parlez connaît
de lourdes difficultés
pour maintenir
le service d'urgence
mais pas simplement
depuis la dernière loi.
Elle était indispensable.
Elle était utile.
Nous avions des mercenaires
qui portaient...
Brouhaha
Des services d'urgence...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Laissez-le parler.
- Aurélien Rousseau:
Cet hôpital
fait partie des hôpitaux
pour lesquels
nous nous battons
au quotidien
avec les personnels
médicaux et notamment
avec le chef du service
des urgences auxquels
je veux rendre hommage.
Ce n'est pas
un hôpital
qui est en train de mourir.
C'est un hôpital sur lequel
nous réinstallons
le service de mammographie.
Nous allons annoncer
des investissements
pour le reconstruire
après l'incendie
qui a eu lieu
il y a quelques années.
Il y a des consultations
avancées
à partir de l'hôpital de Rodez.
Nous nous battons
pour remettre en place
un service de chirurgie
ambulatoire.
Notre combat quotidien
est de permettre
la tenue de ces lignes d'urgence.
Je dois vous rappeler
une règle simple.
Toute urgence vitale
qui se présente
devant le centre est accueillie.
Nous sommes et nous avons mis
en place
une régulation
par le 15 pour dégager
les services d'urgence.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci, monsieur
le ministre,
votre temps est écoulé.
La parole est à madame
Hélène Laporte.
- Hélène Laporte:
Merci, madame la présidente.
Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de l'Agriculture.
Monsieur le ministre,
le 14 décembre dernier,
le Conseil européen
a décidé d'ouvrir
les négociations
en vue de l'adhésion
de l'Ukraine et la Moldavie
à l'Union Européenne.
Cela inquiète
nos agriculteurs,
surtout vu votre engagement
transparent jusqu'à présent.
En cas d'adhésion,
l'Ukraine deviendra
la première puissance
agricole européenne.
Avec une prévision
de 186 milliards
sur sept ans,
c'est le triple
de ce que reçoit
la France entre 2021
et 2027.
L'Ukraine
ne joue pas avec les mêmes
règles que nous.
Le modèle est productiviste.
Vous avez émis le souhait
que le géant agricole ukrainien
cherchera à trouver
des marchés entrés
en concurrence
avec nos producteurs.
Qui peut croire
que nous allons
être en mesure d'éviter
une telle concurrence
alors que l'Union
Européenne est déjà
le premier marché d'export
des produits alimentaires
ukrainiens qui ne font
que progresser?
Vous ne répondez pas,
la réglementation
qui permet l'opacité
sur l'origine
du miel, malgré la crise
apicole française.
Vous répondez
encore que vous n'y pouvez rien.
Les agriculteurs
demandent autre chose.
Alors que vous avez renoncé
à défendre
les éleveurs français
contre la suspension
des droits de douane
sur les produits ukrainiens,
allez-vous enfin placer
notre agriculture française
en tête de votre engagement?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Je vous remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Fesneau.
- Marc Fesneau:
J'ai l'impression
que vous connaissez mal l'Europe.
Je sais que vous êtes gênés.
Vous ne connaissez pas
le fait
qu'il n'y a pas d'étiquetage
européen,
et que ça crée des difficultés.
Le nutri-score
est un dispositif
que nous avons créé sans l'Europe.
Cela arrange votre combat
et vos idéologies.
J'essaie de répondre.
J'aurais aimé
que vous ayez un mot
sur l'Ukraine.
Sur notre solidarité.
La désorganisation
des marchés mondiaux,
c'est pas l'Ukraine,
ce sont vos amis russes
qui l'ont provoquée!
La guerre, c'est vos amis!
L'inflation des prix,
c'est les Russes,
pas les Ukrainiens!
Nous devons être solidaires
des Ukrainiens
et nous devons aussi être lucides.
Nous sommes lucides
dans la négociation.
Si vous connaissiez
l'Europe, vous sauriez
que le processus est long.
C'est la France
qui a fait en sorte
que dans le débat
de l'ouverture
sur les marchés,
on fasse en sorte
que la période soit courte.
On a fait en sorte
que nous ayons
des mesures
pour que les marchés
ne soient pas déstabilisés.
La déstabilisation,
c'est imputable
à vos amis russes
et vous en portez
la responsabilité!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La séance des questions
au gouvernement est terminée.
La séance suspendue.